hi there steve kaufman here uh today i'm
going to talk again about language
learning or more specifically language
study versus more a more natural
approach to learning if you like my
videos please subscribe
when i wrote my book on language
learning about 10 years ago
on the cover
i put and by the way this is the chinese
version that was sold in china
i put this picture of a crooked tree
uh because at the beginning of the book
i had this parable written by drungs are
ascribed to juansa the
taoist or taoist philosopher
about this crooked tree which
represented sort of the natural growth
of things that we have to learn to
appreciate things for what they are
and and in my book there's a number of
references to the sort of call it zen
call it taoist approach to learning
which is sort of a natural
effortlessness i mean drugs are referred
to way like now you're not doing
anything and yet you're learning it's
that sort of passive approach
uh
and um you know it's always been a big
part of my
feeling about language learning i
acquire more words incidentally than i
do through deliberate study
uh
and i looked this up i googled you know
deliberate study versus you know passive
learning or more natural learning and
there was a study in i think saudi
arabia and you'll find this if you
google which again showed that
uh taking two groups of students 50 in
each group those that did the deliberate
study using
i don't know memory techniques synonyms
antonyms and so forth versus those who
studied you know vocabulary through
extensive reading that the group that
did the extensive reading did much much
better
uh
and you know again for example with
german like i i got stuck trying to
learn the declension tables but when i
stopped doing that and simply read and
listened my overall german ability
improved and some of the declensions
just started naturally falling into
place
and very often we're doing these sort of
deliberate learning activities and we
think we're learning and in fact
it just seems to slip through our
fingers within a few days of all of the
you know declensions in russian or
whatever might be have just simply
evaporated
so so that's always been my prejudice
and occasionally i stray from that so
here i am learning hebrew
struggling to
master the hebrew alphabet
where
some of the symbols are completely
different from anything i've seen some
of the symbols resemble you know like an
eye
in english or in the latin alphabet and
yet it's sometimes
sometimes ooh sometimes in and it's very
difficult to get the brain to adapt to
this new
system
and so where i've daily been trying to
read and struggling to read and
struggling to remember what the
meaning of of these significance of
these letters
was i have now adopted a new technique
which i'm going to share with you and
that is to say
that because i study
on my ipad and i have my
many stories here
and of course we have text-to-speech so
i can now read the story
uh
what i've started doing now is i go
through every story i just go through it
and i hear you see
you tell me
and so i with every word that i i press
on with my stylus of course i get the
meaning and i get the sound
so i don't struggle to try and read this
word it tells me what the word is if i
saw that i'm not trying to like to me
this looks like an i o but it's not with
with two little quotation marks but it's
not
it's your c it's not i o it's your c so
you know by doing this often enough it's
going to naturally flow into my brain
that pattern gets sort of established
and it's a lot more pleasant i don't
have to fight it i don't have to
struggle i just go through the lesson
when i'm finished
i listen to the natural voice and i
follow along again
so that i'm giving myself this sort of
more natural exposure to the language
word for word
if the language were written say in an
alphabet that i was more familiar with i
think i would do phrases
but still the idea of going through the
lesson once hearing it in text to speech
whether it be word for word or phrase by
phrase and then again listening to the
human voice read that again and you read
along
is is i'm not forcing myself to do
anything i'm just letting it flow in i'm
spending time with the language
which again is a key you know attitude
spending time with the language and i'm
very suspicious of
learning activities which force you to
think
yeah when they you know
you have quizzes and drills i mentioned
the other day living language tries to
get you to match up these new hebrew
words that supposedly you've learned and
that match them to the corresponding
english word as if this exercise in
forcing you to try and remember
something
is going to have some benefit i it has
not been my experience i i think it
won't have any benefit i'm better off to
spend that time just letting more of the
language wash over me and because in
hebrew of course
getting used to the writing system is is
such a big
hurdle initially and i want to get to
where i can read so that i can listen
and read and follow my normal
learning practices
so i would rather spend my time just
letting the language wash over me and
that's why i think this approach of
going through these lessons just going
through them uh
knocking them off the list there's now
30 mini stories in hebrew i'm going to
go through all 30 mini stories and go
back again go back again i can go back
again with a different objective
you know and i am
some words for you know
preposition or
um
whatever it might be uh you know
adjective adverb
time
you know verbs
but initially i just want to let it wash
over me and so this is an approach and
it's kind of more of a
more of this passive uh
learning as opposed to deliberate study
so i would be interested in hearing from
you how effective is deliberate study
how effective is forcing you to think
uh as opposed to simply allowing you
know exposing yourself to more and more
of the language letting it wash over you
and letting the brain gradually start to
form some patterns
so there you have it deliberate language
study versus a more natural approach to
acquiring the language i would be
interested in hearing your views thank
you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you